any question was if there is unconscious
but just repeated so I'm making sure I
get it right if there is unconscious
bias but how it is why privilege not
exist the question is given that there
is unconscious bias how does white
privilege so okay so number one so when
I select yes when I speak about white
privilege I'm speaking specifically
about behavior okay there have been no
studies and really I've looked at these
studies the the connection between what
they call implicit bias this is their
favorite phrase now implicit bias
unconscious bias and bias behavior has
yet to be proven at any level that is
even remotely necessary to be used in
for example a courtroom which is why
it's never been used in a courtroom it
is also true that there is no way there
there really isn't there's been no
proven way to alleviate what they call
unconscious bias which means that were
ghost-hunting so what I would suggest is
that if there is unconscious bias and
I'll acknowledge the possibility or the
reality of unconscious bias if there is
then I need you to put on about what's
in people's head so much is what they do
so if you point to me to in a racist
behavior I'm a don't worry I'll let you
I'll let you respond if if I if you
point me to a racist behavior I'm happy
to stand alongside you and protest it
what I can't do is protest about things
in people's head that I don't know about
because I'm not a mind-reader okay so
that's a really interesting response and
so that I have two questions
firstly what I've heard you say that
this is something that you know the way
people think doesn't affect their
behavior so that's the first thing
you've said so I'm really curious if you
can kind of give me another example of a
thought that somebody has which doesn't
affect their behavior like do people who
you know support trope not vote for him
like I'm very curious about that yes
secondly okay okay that was okay say
this I can think that I want to ask is
that if it's something that's it's hard
to fix does it mean we shouldn't do
anything about it because you said oh I
don't know if we can change how people
think does that mean we shouldn't try I
mean first of all not a great impression
but beyond that
my voice isn't that low but but beyond
that as far as the the first question
which do people have thoughts that they
that don't manifest in behavior yes all
the time for instance for instance every
thought that you have about walking up
here and strangling me right now I mean
I assume we have thoughts all the time
that don't manifest in behavior and this
is true every single day we consider
thoughts that cross our minds on the
problem with unconscious biases the
ideas you don't even know that you're
having the thought right so how can you
stop it if you don't even know that
you're having it but then we should be
able to gauge the unconscious bias and
its impact on behavior that's why it's
unconscious bias as opposed to conscious
bias really the idea behind unconscious
bias is that it's not even a ghost it's
a ghost of a ghost because you don't
even know you're having the thought so
people like the hope the whole idea
behind diversity training is just is is
the idea that you can retrain people to
stop their chain of thoughts in order so
that it doesn't manifest in behavior I
don't think that every thought
manifesting behavior if it did then
every time a man saw a good-looking
woman walk down the street a straight
man saw a good-looking woman down the
street we'd have a real mess on our
hands so the the second question the
idea was was a little too broad for me
to respond to which is just because
something is tough then we have to face
up to it yes we have to face up to tough
things all the time and one of the tough
things I would suggest that we face up
to is that you have a lot more control
over your own behavior and the decisions
you make then the supposedly widespread
unconscious bias of people you've never
met